quels liens unissent vases antiques
assez plat une femme isabelle diguet une
prof qui enseigne la créativité à des
étudiants en cuisine vous et vous allez
créer quelque chose
le groupe d'étudiants d'isabelle a
rendez vous avec l'art ils rencontrent
pas vitra artiste multidisciplinaire
d'origine sri lankaise
c'est magnifique parce que pavie traum
ecr amazing et l'artiste qu'on a choisi
cette année elle même s'est inspiré d'un
petit vase d'un petit pot qui date du
15ème siècle et qui fait passer la
collection permanente du musée des
beaux-arts
donc elle même est parti d'une idée et à
fly et elle est partie et dans ses
souvenirs dans ses mémoires dans ses
lancers émotion à elles pour créer son
oeuvre elle le défi pour ces étudiants
créer un plat inspiré de cette oeuvre
d'art
donc je suis arrivé devant la pièce je
me suis un peu ce pays je me suis dit
bon ok ça va être plus difficile en plus
qu'est ce que je pensais elle parle de
son oeuvre pendant au moins une heure et
demie et leur demande de créer
donc un plat avec des éléments imposés
par leur chef en cuisine les ingrédients
avec lesquels vous avez travaillé
on y va avec leveaux et les coquillages
et doivent donc la ferme en une
rétrospection un humain et se demander
qu'est ce que le velours a provoqué
comme et c'est comme sensation et
d'écrire un texte est de voir comment
ils ont transposé toutes ces émotions là
où ses effets dans une assiette mais je
campe le 6 une dimension personnelle je
veux que à partir de l'oeuvre d'art que
eux mêmes créé une autre oeuvre d'art
je voudrais qu'on fasse une espèce de
tempête d'idées ou de brainstorming pour
sortir le plus d'aidé possible pour
transposer tout ça en place qu'est ce
qui vous vient comme ça tout de suite
on repense à à l'oeuvre aussi stephen
rondeurs web au cous à tourner quel
registre la rotation à l'intérieur même
temps au début et c'est un peu perplexe
il se demande où je veux aller il y a
que les à l'idée d'aller au musée ça
passionne certains d'autres salir un peu
peu plus froid mais après ils se
prennent au jeu il adore ça les
étudiants ont transposé en mots et en
dessin leur rencontre avec l'oeuvre de
pavie tra et ce matin c'est le grand
jour
c'est la présentation de leurs créations
culinaires au panel formé de l'artiste
les enseignants et quelques invités ps
que ça doit être bon et pour deux voix
très bon niveau de cash aux faux qu'il
ya différentes textures différentes
formes différentes couleurs faut qu'il
respecte toutes là la tradition
populaire de la gastronomie
ces délais la sensation c'est vraiment
une expérience très spéciale pour moi
chaque étudiant c'est très différent
elle fait une chose est sûre avec le
comme le même ingrédient mais le même
temps c'est très très différents aussi
avec les couleurs et les textures
disparation aussi mon enfant en
inspiration s'était vraiment investi mon
par des personnes peu trop tôt
kylie
les ombres ça me faisait penser un peu
avait sommé refus à cause du mans avec
tout et la pointe de fumée
le moma qui s'est éteint ça représente
et des personnes
si c'était niais tranquillement ça m'a
inspiré beaucoup de souvenirs mais
surtout beaucoup de paix les oignons
frits c'est pour elle et son amant jeu
souvenir que ce sont fossilisés au fil
du temps puis la brioche finalement
quand j'allais finir le plat ça va être
vraiment s qui veut tout lier ensemble
c'est
c'est en pensez c'est ma marque
comment vous allez trouver cet exercice
là strauss hauer madame diguiny pousse
tellement dans les réflexions
c'est juste magnifique qu'on a un un
cours de créativité dans le cours de
formation